kein strom faz einspruch der podcast der
die woche neu verhandelt herzlich
willkommen zum einspruch podcast am 17
20.18 es ist die achte folge und wieder
begrüßen sie hier
corinna bruders und konstantin
vonlanthen ja und wir sind heute ganz
besonders beschwingt denn das hat sich
für uns einige technische verbesserungen
ergeben wir sitzen jetzt tatsächlich in
einem kleinen tonstudio am kopfhörer auf
und sitzen wie immer vor dem mikrofon
ist alles ein wenig professionelle und
macht auch gleich mehr spaß
ja das kommt uns wahnsinnig futuristisch
vor dieser podcast marschiert nach vorne
jetzt auch in technischer hinsicht repos
nachdem ein kleines foto davon auf
twitter dann könnt ihr auch mal sehen
wie dieser raum eigentlich aussieht wir
hier sitzen ja nicht zu viel erwarten
aber schon das ist für uns eine ganz
große verbesserung wunderbar ja so es
gibt wir haben oft in den vergangenen
wochen berichtet dass wir dranbleiben
werden in den verschiedenen themen und
tun das auch jetzt bei der scharia
polizei gab es neuigkeiten
genau da hatten wir in der folge nummer
drei mal ausführlich darüber gesprochen
das war damals die verhandlung am bgh
und inzwischen hat der bgh ein urteil
gefällt das so aussieht dass er die
freisprüche gegen diese sepia polizei
uns aufgehoben hat und die sache
zurückverwiesen ans landgericht
mit dem argument die also beginnen jetzt
wenn die details was ist da alles so zu
beherzigen gab haben wir damals
besprochen aber der bgh sagt jetzt
jedenfalls die frage ob diese
einschüchternde militante bedrohliche
wirkung die eben vom uniform
funktioniert wird ob die hier bestanden
hat oder nicht
das hätte man eben noch konkreter prüfen
müssen und auch gerade mit blick auf die
frage wie das für den für die
adressierte gruppe also für junge
muslime ausgesehen haben muss ob die
sich nicht vielleicht doch gedacht haben
könnte nur jeder hat sich jetzt aus der
muslimischen community heraus quasi so
was wie eine religiöse bürgerwehr
entwickelt und die jetzt geht es an den
kragen wenn wir nicht die scharia
befolgen das hätte man genauer prüfen
müssen das wird das landgericht jetzt
tun müssen und insofern bleibt uns
leider nicht mehr zu sagen als wir
bleiben erneut ran wenn dann irgendwann
mal eine weitere entscheidung kommt aber
so viel jedenfalls zum bgh dann noch ein
zweiter ganz kurzer nachtrag haben wir
der letzten sendung darüber gesprochen
die beiden lux leaks liga die in
revision gegangen sind und der tour und
raphael allee für rafael allee ist es
bei seiner verurteilung geblieben der
wird jetzt vor den europäischen
gerichtshof für menschenrechte ziehen
uns auch die letzte instanz ziehen da
potenzial noch helfen könnte und wann
das urteil wurde aufgehoben und
ebenfalls zur erneuten verhandlung
zurückverwiesen also auch da selber
befund das ganze zieht sich noch ein
bisschen länger
so viel zu den versprochenen nachträgen
dann kommen wir auch gleich zu den
themen der heutigen folge
als da wären zunächst einmal eine
entscheidung des bundesgerichtshofs in
sachen heinz gegen mainz der ehemalige
torwart des sv heinz müller hat sich
dagegen gewehrt dass sein arbeitsvertrag
befristet wurde und wir schauen uns mal
an warum er damit letztlich keinen
erfolg gehabt hat anschließend geht es
um eine entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts dass bei einer
ziemlichen gretchenfrage gestanden hat
nämlich ob es eigentlich das zulässt
oder nicht das rumänische straftäter
straff verdächtige nach rumänien
abgeschoben werden das ist ein bisschen
fraglich weil die haftbedingungen in
rumänien alles andere als state of the
art sind so dann werden wir eins einer
debatte widmen die jetzt schon seit
einigen monaten tobt im grunde genommen
nämlich die frage ob es nicht mal
wirklich an der zeit wäre die
strafbarkeit von schwarzfahren
abzuschaffen und ob das nicht besser in
einem ordnungswidrigkeiten tatbestand
aufgehoben werden zu guter letzt haben
wir dann erneut einem gast in der
sendung das wird diesmal der journalist
richard gutjahr sein der leider muss man
sagen aus der innenansicht sehr
detailliert beschreiben können wie es
eigentlich ist sich einem einer
regelrechten trolle armee im netz
gegenüber zu sehen und mit hass
überzogen zu werden und der kann dann
auch mal berichten ob sich jetzt
eigentlich für ihn durch das netz dg
etwas geändert hat
jetzt aber erstmal zum bbi ag und zu
heinz müller
richtig es geht um fußball und das ist
mal wieder ein schönes beispiel das
recht und fußball ganz schön verbindet
und auch für leute interessant sind die
wir beide jetzt hier nicht die
allergrößten fußballfans in jedenfalls
constantin du bist als solcher
jedenfalls noch nicht in erscheinung
getreten oder wie ich bin sogar die
schlimmste also ich glaube fußball fans
finden das was ich mache am
allerschlimmsten weil ich mich nämlich
normalerweise nicht dafür interessiere
und dann zur em und zwei wm aber auf
einmal zu voller form auflaufen und also
eine eine diva sondern auch etwa mit wie
ihr ich bin ja ich habe ich schreie mit
ihm förmlich also ich bin selber mal
ganz über mich erstaunt welche
begeisterung und parteinahme ich dann
auf einmal entwickeln kann aber das wäre
dann eben auch immer nur für die paar
wochen die so eine em wm eben dauert und
danach klingt es wieder richtig und geht
mir ganz ähnlich und letztendlich ist es
natürlich auch ein ziemlich schlüpfriges
parkett in dem heim gut ausrutschen kann
wenn man muss noch einfach ein
fußballclub hat aussprechen und schon
wird einem das wochenlang nachgetragen
aber wir versuchen es trotzdem denn in
dieses urteil vom bundesarbeitsgericht
ist für viele leute interessant denn wir
wollen sie jetzt mal zu anlass nehmen
uns die befristung von arbeitsverträgen
mal genauer anzugucken und davon sind ja
immer mehr leute in deutschland
betroffen
also dass vielleicht das kuriose vorweg
auch profi fußballer sind arbeitnehmer
im sinne des gesetzes das ganz normale
aber ganz wichtig weisungsgebunden ja
auch keine leitenden angestellten obwohl
man das von dem gehalt vielleicht
manchmal denken könnte
aber sie sind eben stinknormale
arbeitnehmer und als solche haben sie
auch rechten rechte wie jeder andere
arbeitnehmer auch und da ist es eben so
dass in deutschland befristete
arbeitsverträge möglich sind aber nur in
relativ engen grenzen die arbeitgeber
seien
natürlich immer einen zu engen grenzen
und umgekehrt sagt jetzt insbesondere
die spd aber eben auch linke und grüne
zum beispiel die sachgrundlose
befristung einfach zu viel und die
würden sie ganz gerne abgeschafft haben
allerdings haben die jetzt in der sonne
in sondierungsgesprächen keine rolle
gespielt bzw
jedenfalls kam es dann nicht zu
ergebnissen
worum geht also bei den befristeten
arbeitsverträgen war ganz kurz vorne weg
also gefragt
mit einem sachgrund befristet kann man
immer das ist zb die vereinsvertreter
absolut genau das ist relativ problemlos
möglich
und hier ging es aber in dem fall von
heinz müller um eine sachgrundlose
befristung ja also die eben im
profifußball relativ üblich ist ich habe
bei meinem kollegen der wiederum ein
markus jung den sie ja auch schon von
der vergangenen woche kennen der hat die
berichterstattung hier für uns bei der
faz und in für ein spruch gemacht der
ist nun auch ausgewiesener fußball fan
und von dem habe ich gelernt dass das
ganz üblich ist zwei bis drei jahre für
jüngere für jüngere spieler auch mal
fünf jahre und heinz müller hat eben
auch so einen vertrag und eine klausel
noch darin dass eine verlags
vertragsverlängerung von einem jahr noch
zusätzlich winkt sie wenn er denn eine
bestimmte anzahl von spielen absolviert
das ist dann ihm im alter von 34 jahren
irgendwie nicht mehr ganz so gelungen er
sei es dann häufiger auf der bank
er hat sich glaube ich dann irgendwann
auch verletzt gehen dann danach musste
erstmal zwangsweise aussetzen und wurde
dann aber danach nicht mehr eingesetzt
und dann sollte irgendwann vertrag
glaube ich mit 214 oder so auslaufen und
ist das auch genau und er wurde eben
auch nicht mehr verlängert und dagegen
hatte er geklagt bis hin nach erfurt bis
zum bundesarbeitsgericht und die haben
jetzt nun in dieser frage ein
endgültiges urteil gefällt und zwar
haben sie jetzt mal vielleicht dieses
ergebnis vorweg war das für viele
fußball verbände und fußballfans ganz
wichtig war im grunde genommen
diese ganze praxis abgesegnet die über
jahre hinweg ziemlich umstritten war
also
festgestellt für den profisport gibt es
eine ausnahme die eine eigenheit des
arbeits der arbeitsleistung liegt er
also von profifußballern wird im
wesentlichen erwartet dass sich
spitzenleistung bringen und das kann man
nicht über einen langen zeitraum
jedenfalls nicht für immer und deswegen
ist es möglich diese befristung zu
machen das ist jetzt also
höchstrichterlich entschieden im übrigen
fänden die fenster ist ja auch ganz
interessant wenn der personell
gelegentlich mal ein bisschen was
durchmarschiert und nicht wie bei einer
behörde irgendwie die leute 30 jahre
ihren dienst tun
30 jahre schon sowieso nicht aber und
das ist finde ich ganz interessant weil
wie so manches im arbeitsrecht ist halt
eigentlich nicht so klar im gesetz steht
eigentlich eher das gegenteil dessen im
gesetz steht zunächst einmal was die
möglichkeit der sachgrundlosen
befristung angeht aber ist dann eben an
dieses kriterium eigenheit dass der
arbeitsleistung oder des
arbeitsverhältnisses geknüpft wird das
dann doch gehen sollen
das ist eine auffang tatbestand
sozusagen also das ganze findet sich im
in paragraf 14 des teilzeit- und
befristungsgesetz wäre es man nachlesen
möchte da ist es ziemlich dezidiert
aufgelistet also sachgrundlose
befristung gehen in deutschland
eigentlich nur zwei jahre lang und dann
eben nicht mehr
und im fußball ist es eben wie gesagt
was anderes da ist explizit eben die der
tatbestand der eigenheit der
arbeitsleistung genannt und darunter
fassen die bundesarbeitsrichter profi
fußballer aber auch andere leute also es
gab in jüngerer vergangenheit auch in
den fall eines eines kommissars eines
fernseh kommissare geklagt hatte der
wurde und wie aus dem war es nicht der
alte
ausgesprochen wird sich weil der alte zu
alt brachte richtig und was da eben auch
besonders schön war ist das hier auch
dem
dem zdf das glaube ich ihm zugesprochen
wurde dass die auch für eine verjüngung
sorgen können trotz titel da mal ein
bisschen ein frischer wind weht durch
wählen darf und dann dürfen sie ihm auch
diesen fernsehkommissarin also die
arriva nicht gestrichen sondern wir
haben die rolle neu besetzt mit einem
jüngeren schauspieler und er hat im
prinzip mit einer ähnlichen
argumentation wieder mal ja gesagt mein
vertrag war zu unrecht befristet und
auch im übrigen kann man ein ganz
normaler und miteinander werben
ungewöhnliche name ja genau und das fand
ich auch ganz interessant in dieser
entscheidung dass das bier geht durchaus
auch auf presse rundfunk und
kunstfreiheit der sendungs gestalter
abgestellt hat na das ist ja auch nicht
so ganz selbstverständlich und das haben
sie glaube ich dann noch in einer nicht
das brg aber jedenfalls die
arbeitsgerichtsbarkeit noch in einer
dritten entscheidung getan oder doch war
das arbeitsgericht auch im fall einer
maskenbildnerin das fand ich ganz
ehrlich gesagt da wurde eben auch drauf
auf die eigene arbeitsleistung
hingewiesen und unter diesem doch recht
schwammigen begriff eben gefasst dass
auch eine maskenbildnerin befristet
eingestellt werden darf und dann eben
einfach auch ins leere läuft
wenn der vertrag nicht verlängern wird
das fand ich ein bisschen grenzwertig
übrigens ein das ist schön nachzulesen
in einem aktuellen artikel den wir in
faz einspruch magazin jetzt heute auf
die webseite stellen werden das gerne
mal nachlesen möchte und der www.faz.net
genau dankeschön die ihre vertreter man
noch nicht fest
ja das der referiert noch mal die ganze
rechtsprechung in diesem bereich und
geht da noch etwas mehr in die tiefe als
wir das an dieser stelle können wir
packen euch gerne den link dazu in die
schweiz
und vielleicht wird jetzt in zukunft
also das schöne ist ja in diesem fall
übrigens dass er jetzt abgeschlossen ist
das heißt vom bundesarbeitsgericht wir
müssen jetzt nicht noch eine weitere
entscheidung von bh oder wem auch immer
warten dass für die profifußballer ist
jetzt nun geklärt die frage ist aber was
das eben für andere berufsgruppen noch
offen hält denn was wir hier tatsächlich
sehen ist ein bisschen so eine
durchlöcherung des paragrafen 14 also
der sachgrundlosen befristung das wird
alles offensichtlich jetzt ein bisschen
die gera gehandhabt von den obersten
bundesrichter in für den profifußball
kann man es ja auch verstehen man könnte
sich das ist jetzt nicht gerade das
bekehre arbeitsverhältnis man sich
irgendwie so in sozialer hinsicht große
sorgen machen müssten aber im übrigen
wird diese regelung ja auch schon seit
menschengedenken nach lust und laune
umgangen stichworte ketten befristung
und so deren bzw
auch die ist ja abgesegnet hätten
befristung ist ein wunderbares stichwort
aber da geht es oft um befristung die im
öffentlichen dienst statt finden also
das ist echt gesagt auch eine ganz
schräge nummer die mich immer so ein
bisschen zu hass attacken führt denn da
sind wirklich ganz bemerkenswerte fälle
dabei also grundschullehrer die über 14
jahre hinweg immer wieder hätten
arbeitsverträge jedes jahr aufs neue
verlängert werden und das auch mit der
allergrößten selbstverständlichkeit
passiert ja weil der öffentliche dienst
der staat eben knappe mittel hat und
dann werden eben solche befristung
schloss anstatt die leute vernünftig
einzustellen und da das hat auch schon
oft die bundesgerichte beschäftigt auch
den ogh mal und zuletzt hat eben der
bundesarzt bundesarbeitsgericht so eine
art missbrauchs prüfung eingeführt also
ketten arbeitsverhältnisse sind vom
prinzip
ok wenn sie also dazu braucht man
natürlich immer ein sachgrund also in
den der ist der lässt sich ja dann
leicht finden
wir haben ja schon gesagt die vertretung
ist immer ein sachgrund oder jedenfalls
in den meisten fällen aber da auch da
gibt es dann eben grenzen und da hat das
bundesarbeitsgericht in eine
bemerkenswerte entscheidung vom oktober
2016 die packen wir auch gerne nochmal
in die show nutzt da so ein prüfung
schema aufgebaut die im wesentlichen
gesagt haben also das ganze ist noch
okay wenn die befristung acht jahren
nicht überschreitet oder nicht mehr als
zwölf vertragsverlängerung vereinbart
werden also nicht mehr und dann kommen
wir eben die ampel schaltet auf gelb
also dann wird eben schon schwieriger
wenn eben die acht jahre überschritten
sind oder die zwölf
vertrags-verlängerung ja dann kann ein
missbrauch vorliegen
aber den muss übrigens die arbeitnehmer
belegen indem er etwa einen dauerhaften
vertretungs bedarf her beim arbeitgeber
nachweis ist jetzt auch nicht die
einfachste würde nie um ein überspringen
kann und ganz schlimm wird es aber wenn
das arbeitsverhältnis die gesamtdauer
von zehn jahren überschreitet oder die
befristung mehr als 15 mal vereinbart
wurde
ja das finde ich ehrlich gesagt eine
viel problematischer entscheidung noch
als die jetzt aktuell hin
er hat richtig dass dieses prinzip der
des losen befristung verbot in
bestimmtem randbereichen ein bisschen
aufgeweicht wird das kann man so oder so
sehen aber diese dieses thema ketten der
frühsommer dass es da also nach acht
jahren und zwölf befristungen sollte man
mal ein bisschen genauer hinschauen aber
könnte immer noch nicht missbräuchlich
sein dass salat aber meine niemals wird
kommt noch dollar also jetzt haben wir
hier tatsächlich mal einen verein gehabt
wo es um die sechzehnte vertrags
ja und in dieser phase ist es übrigens
so das ist keineswegs so ist dass das
automatisch jetzt ein missbrauch
festgestellt wird dass man gar nicht
mehr rum diskutiert und gar keine
rechtfertigung hören möchte ganz im
gegenteil der arbeitgeber kann sich dazu
äußern und zwar wenn er nachweist dass
er eine akribische vertretungs planung
durchgeführt hat und das ist in dem
einen fall auch tatsächlich wohl
gelungen da war ihm die sechzehnte
ketten befristung auch noch wirksam weil
der eben ziemlich dezitiert nachgewiesen
hatten wir müssen jetzt ziemlich um
schieben und da haben wir noch eine
lehrerin ließ und wie jetzt abkömmlich
und dann schieben wir den kollegen eben
hier rein und da war auch die
sechzehnter ketten befristung und noch
in ordnung also insofern dass dann will
ich dir total zuströmen also bei heinz
müller
wenn man den auch mal so sieht kann man
sich auch vorstellen dass ja auch
alternative karriere in planung
ich weiß es nicht so genau ich bin pro
wrestling ist ja bei war früheren
fußball spielen
so kam ich gehört jedenfalls scheint er
da auch sehr engagierte typ zu sein und
da muss man sich vielleicht auch nicht
die größten sorgen an und gut verdient
wird er ja vorher auch
der hat übrigens beim 1 gespielt das
haben niemals zu keinem zeitpunkt jemals
erwähnen das sieht man wieder das was
wir für doch 1 gegen mainz also es
stimmt also um eins muss man sich heinz
müller muss man sich keine gedanken
machen aber ich finde die ketten
befristung ist etwas was man mal im
blick halten sollte auch die politik im
blick halten sollte denn wie gesagt es
ist oft der start der tiefe ein bad und
nicht etwa in die privatwirtschaft
ja das könnte die spd ja in die
koalitionsverhandlung noch mal schön
mitnehmen und sich dann von der union
überrollen lassen wie so häufig aber das
finde ich wirklich also am ende der
sendung kommt noch dass gerechte urteil
diese entscheidung des bbi ag aus 216
ist das ungerechte urteile so jedenfalls
nach meinem empfinden ich glaube auch
nach corinnas ja ich würde sagen damit
lassen wir es zu diesem themenblock
bewenden
noch mal einer sagen fußball würde
keinen bildungsauftrag erfüllen den
server gleich noch generell ein bisschen
das thema befristung im arbeitsrecht
auch über den fußball hinaus referiert
kommen dann zu einer sache die für die
leben die praktische lebenswirklichkeit
der meisten hörer jetzt wahrscheinlich
nicht ganz so relevant aber trotzdem von
großen rechtlichen interesse ist das
bundesverfassungsgericht sah sich vor
einer ziemlichen zwickmühle stehen denn
es hatte einen fall auf dem tisch bei
dem es eigentlich noch falsch
entscheiden konnte könnte man sagen da
war ein rumäne der hat
verfassungsbeschwerde erhoben gegen
seine auslieferung nach rumänien dort
wird er von den strafverfolgungsbehörden
gesucht wegen work uns und
vermögensdelikten und er hat eben
verfassungsbeschwerde erhoben mit dem
argument die auslieferung wurde gegen
seine menschenwürde verstoßen denn die
haftbedingungen in rumänien seien
menschenunwürdig
dazu muss man wissen dass eigentlich
innerhalb der eu diese auslieferungen in
aller regel und so ist es auch gedacht
ohne große weitere prüfung stattfinden
sollen stichwort raum der freiheit
sicherheit und des rechts der nicht
umsonst sind eine hier in der
europäischen union haben bestimmte
mindeststandards zu erfüllen genau aber
nur weil man die zu erfüllen hat heißt
es eben leider noch nicht dass man sie
auch tatsächlich erfüllen würde in
rumänien liegt ja ohne in
infrastrukturell und auch politisch so
manches im argen und leider muss man
sagen wenn die länder in einem geld
knapp sind dann fließen sie sicherlich
nicht als erstes da hinein
besonders tolle haftbedingungen für
strenge zu schaffen in rumänien sieht
also so aus dass hatten die männchen
behörden zugesichert dass strafgefangene
einen persönlichen raum von mindestens
drei quadratmetern oder wenn sie im
offenen vollzug sind mindestens zwei
quadratmetern pro person haben werden
das ist natürlich wahnsinnig wenig also
mit anderen worten diese zu leicht gehen
der massentierhaltung mehrfach
unterbringung natürlich ne also wer
teilt man sich dann die zähler
genau das dass man das natürlich auch
einzeln zumeist schon mal sowieso nicht
und da hatte also daneben zunächst bevor
es zum
zum bundesverfassungsgericht ging das
oberlandesgericht hamburg noch darüber
zu entscheiden
und das hat gesagt ja wissen wir schauen
dass das irgendwie in rumänien alles
jetzt nicht zum besten bestellt ist habe
sind auch gewisse fortschritte beim
dortigen strafvollzug auszumachen es
gibt zum beispiel sehr weitgehender
ausschluss zeiten also die häftlinge
dürfen dann häufiger man aus der zelle
raus es sind die baulichen
voraussetzungen für freigänge geschaffen
worden
auch im hinblick auf heizung
sanitäranlagen und hygiene und
hafturlaub oder den empfang von besuch
in der haft und das war schon von
privater wäsche hätte sich manches
verbessert insofern sei es also alles in
allem vertretbar den mann dann
abzuschieben dann hat er eben
verfassungsbeschwerde erhoben und des
bundesverfassungsgerichts stand jetzt
deshalb von einer schwierigen wahl weil
es entweder mit durchaus guten
argumenten sagen konnten die bedingungen
sind aber immer noch dort
menschenunwürdig ja das hätte dann aber
zur folge gehabt dass deutschland zum
sicheren hafen für männliche straftäter
geworden werden können dann hier
hinkommt werden nicht ausgeliefert
werden von deutschen
strafverfolgungsbehörden nicht verfolgt
und können dann hier einfach die füße
hochlegen und sich freuen und lachen
über die dummheit der menschen
strafverfolgung der deutschen justiz und
umgekehrt nur wollte man ihn aber
natürlich auch nicht gegen die immer
noch doch recht deutlich bestehenden
bedenken ausliefern
und das ist eben die lämmer vielleicht
sagt man in dieser stelle nochmal hier
geht es eben nicht um flüchtlinge
sondern es ist eben ein eu spezifisches
problem was mein film wo man vielleicht
eine kleine parallele ziehen kann zu den
hartz vier fällen die wir in den
vergangenen jahren gesehen haben die
auch zu heftigen diskussionen geführt
haben also wieder
aus osteuropäischen staaten das ist die
einwanderung in die sozialsysteme
so wurde immer argumentiert und das wo
wurde ein bisschen als schreckgespenst
auch an die wand gemalt und im grunde
genommen die die freizügigkeit der
europäischen union missbraucht für genau
meinem fall geben um irgendwie bessere
sozialleistungen abzugreifen oder dann
jetzt hier um nicht ausgeliefert zu
werden wie gesagt eigentlich ist die
auslieferung zwischen einige staaten
vorgesehen beziehungsweise um das
gefängnis ganz zu umgehen
die argumentation war ja dann eben auch
dass man jetzt die deutschen behörden
das wären die alternativen dass sie
sozusagen die straftäter dann hier auch
in deutschland verfolgen und aber das
werden die deutschen behörden eben nicht
tun das ist einfach es ist auch nicht
praktika also die straftat eines rumänen
in rumänien erstens die frage ob die
deutschen den staatsanwaltschaften
überhaupt zuständig werden und zweitens
wie willst du das dann mittels das
aufklärende da stößt man ja dann auch
wirklich an seine grenzen und kann auch
nicht die strafverfolgung arbeit anderer
eu staaten übernehmen und deshalb weil
deren acht bedingungen so schlecht sind
dass es nicht über uns bringen die leute
da wieder hin zurückzustehen also das
war ja wirklich behandelt findet deshalb
auch nicht statt aber nun hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht also einen
anderen weg gewählt das hat nämlich
weder gesagt also weder die auslieferung
zugelassen noch gesagt dass gegen die
menschenwürde verstößt sondern die
entscheidung des olg verstoße gegen den
artikel 101 absatz 1 satz 2 grundgesetz
also die gewährleistung des gesetzlichen
richters weil das olg den europäischen
gerichtshof hätte anrufen müssen warum
jetzt das weil so sagt das
verfassungsgericht eben die lage in
hinblick auf die rumänischen
haftbedingungen nicht ausreichend europa
rechtlich geklärt sei
das müsse europaweit einheitlich
entschieden werden also es könne dann
eben auch nicht sein dass manche staaten
sorgen höchst schon fein beschrieben die
leute da alle nach rumänien zurück und
andere nicht und deshalb hätte der ogh
das hier entscheiden müssen ob sie nun
letzten endes vertretbar ist die leute
laden auszuliefern oder nicht das ist
natürlich sicherlich
so lässt sich lässt sich hören aber die
sache verzögert die sache der mann
musste jetzt auch erstmal frei gelassen
werden denn der ist ja bisher ist ja
noch gar nicht strafrechtlich verurteilt
gegen ihn wird nun ermittelt
also weiß man ja noch nicht mal ob er
wirklich überhaupt irgendwas angestellt
hat und genau also für den ist es auf
jeden fall mal hier glimpflich
ausgegangen wobei jetzt auch nicht
unbegrenzt hier in deutschland bleiben
darf
das wird dann immer immer so ein
bisschen jaja freizügigkeit natürlich
schon erstmal und jedoch nie denn das
ist das ja auch an enge grenzen gesetzt
also wenn man hier zur arbeitssuche zb
und oder sich selbst versorgen kann ja
finanziell abgesichert ist ansonsten ich
glaube sechs monate beziehen sind
maximal ein jahr darf man sich
eigentlich zur arbeit sowie in
deutschland aufhalten
gucken wir mal wie dann also der ogh
hier letzten endes in dieser sache
entscheiden wird bis dahin hat rumänien
ja vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen
zeit die offenbar laufenden
verbesserungen des deutschen dortigen
strafvollzugs war weiter zu treiben
das soll es zu diesem thema gewesen sein
wir kommen jetzt zu einer debatte von
der er wahrscheinlich alle schon mal
gehört hat in den letzten monaten die
geht immer wieder auf corinna worum geht
es dabei um das erschleichen von
leistungen das nämlich strafbar ist nach
§ 265 a des strafgesetzbuches und damit
ist das vor allen dingen das
schwarzfahren gemeint aber übrigens auch
nicht nur das sondern auch der zutritt
zu einer veranstaltung oder zu einer
einrichtung also wer sich in ein museum
drückt wahrscheinlich ohne zu bezahlen
wäre auch ein kandidat ist der mit
abstand wichtigste anwendungsfeld
absolut und eins das auch wirklich ein
anwendungsfall der die behörden auch
durchaus an ihre belastungsgrenzen
bringt so komisch es klingt aber es ist
eben dadurch dass eine straftat ist das
wird übrigens nicht nicht sofort sondern
eben bei notorischen start war
wird dann auch die staatsanwaltschaft
alarmiert meistens von den jeweiligen
regionalen verkehrsverbünden ob es eine
mvs oder die bvg in berlin oder wie auch
immer also wenn das beim ersten mal den
lässt man dann womöglich noch laufen mit
gegen einen die berühmten 40 und 60 euro
wie viel es auch immer noch mehr ist ich
muss mich inzwischen ja ich weiß nämlich
nur weil das überall jetzt klebt jemals
gelaufen wäre nein aber ja 60 euro genau
aber dann wenn da einer eben immer
wieder auffällt dann geben die das an
die staatsanwaltschaften ab und die sind
dann natürlich aufgrund des legalität
grundsatzes auch verpflichtet das zu
verfolgen obwohl sie womöglich
wichtigere und dringendere dinge auf dem
tisch liegen haben genau und es tut
übrigens eine freiheitsstrafe bis zu
einem jahr oder geldstrafe also dass
auch noch mal um die sache abzurunden
für alle die sich da vielleicht ertappt
fühlen also wie gesagt ein
straftatbestand und die diskussion die
wir jetzt hier sehen ist das schon seit
geraumer zeit einige justizminister das
wort ergreifen und der deutsche
richterbund und sagen das müsste
entkriminalisiert werden
aus rein pragmatischen gründen es bindet
einfach zu viele ressourcen personeller
und finanzieller art was nämlich
passiert ist dass staatsanwälte und ihm
richter mit solchen fällen betraut
betraut werden
angeblich soll es so sein dass in berlin
rechnerisch zumindest 20 staatsanwälte
und richter ganzjährig mit solchen
verfahren beschäftigt sind allein da und
man weiß ja wirklich die justiz knarzt
und ächzt unter der verfahrens lässt und
das äußert sich auf mannigfaltige art
und weise mitunter müssen leute aus
untersuchungshaft entlassen werden weil
nicht schnell genug entschieden werden
kann
mitunter gehen schlicht
fehlentscheidungen
[Musik]
vieles so zu sagen könnte man mit mehr
zeit und mit mehr personal besser machen
und dann stellt sich schon die frage na
ja dann könnte man natürlich auch
einfach sagen wir schaffen eben etwas
mehr personal aber das ist wiederum aus
anderem naheliegenden gründen nicht
durchführbar kostet ja auch alles geld
muss auch irgendwo herkommen und dann
ist eben das pragmatische argument zu
sagen also müssen wir diese leute jetzt
wirklich muss man darauf unsere
ressourcen verwenden gibt es da nicht
drängendere probleme wie siehst du das
denn ja es ist übrigens es geht gerade
noch weiter also es sind eben nicht nur
die personellen ressourcen sondern auch
wenn es soweit kommt dass leute
verknackt werden
realistischerweise eine geldstrafe erst
dann und dient dann nicht zahlen dann
droht ersatzhaft er und was kommt gerne
mal von den ja genau das sind ja nicht
nur aber sicherlich zu einem
überproportionalen anteil leute die eben
auch einfach keine kohle haben er
vielleicht waren sie ja gerade deshalb
schwarz weil sie schwierigkeiten haben
sich das ticket zu leisten werden sie
erst recht schwierigkeiten haben die
gerichtliche dann ihnen auferlegte
geldstrafe zu zahlen und dann ist nur
pro tagessatz den man sagen wir mal
jemand bekommt 30 tagessätze kann die
aber nicht zahlen dann geht er eben pro
tagessatz ein tag in haft also in dem
fall 30 tage
und das ist natürlich auch klar jetzt
ist im strafvollzug kein kein irgendwie
unternehmen das auf gewinnmaximierung
gerichtet wäre aber es ist schon auch
uhren sonntag in haft kostet den staat
ja eine ganze menge geld also auch da
kann man fragen ist es eigentlich
sinnvoll dass wir dann sozusagen jetzt
noch die die strafvollzugs ressourcen
darauf verwenden diese leute die blues
schwarz gefahren sind irgendwie in haft
zu halten und es sind auch keine kleinen
sein
das muss man vielleicht dazu auch noch
sagen also angeblich ist es so dass im
allein im herbst neben vergangenen jahr
sollen in nrw 1200 gefangene wegen einer
ersatzfreiheitsstrafe in haft in haft
gegangen sein
wegen schwarzfahren stolze zahl
es haben sich ja schon mehrere
justizminister ich meine derjenige aus
nrw und der aus berlin tatsächlich dafür
ausgesprochen haben das abschaffen
beziehungsweise in einen
ordnungswidrigkeiten taten staaten
führen süchtig und das ist ja übrigens
auch nicht das ende der debatte
wir sagen jetzt nicht hier hopp oder top
sondern es ist ja man könnte überlegen
und da bin ich auch inzwischen ein
großer verfechter dafür zu überlegen ob
man daraus nicht ein
ordnungswidrigkeiten eine
ordnungswidrigkeit machen soll wie ist
übrigens in vielerlei hinsicht schon
passiert also wir sehen es zum beispiel
beim über die rote ampel fahren das ist
eine ordnungswidrigkeit falschparken das
eine ordnungswidrigkeit das heißt das
sind alles keine straftaten die
wahrscheinlich sogar also ähnlichen
unrechtsgehalt haben womöglich auch eine
größere gefährdung oder zumindest eine
größere finanzielle belastung darstellen
für den staat und das fänd ich sinnvoll
an dieser stelle
interessanterweise einwenden es gibt ja
ein wenn die dann sagen naja aber bei
der deutschen bahn sind die ticket
preise höher und wenn man da nicht mehr
strafrechtlich vorgehen kann er dann ist
dem unheil tür und tor geöffnet zu
meistern müssten so nach dem motto da
mussten die anderen regulierten
fahrgäste quasi querfinanzieren die
verluste sie die bahn allein
ja so wird immer dann argumentiert da
ist der ehrliche der dumme aber das
finde ich ehrlich gesagt nicht denn man
weiß schichten greifen das schwarzfahren
sich nicht gehört ja dass man es nicht
macht und deswegen hat man ja auch diese
peinlichkeit moment wenn man erwischt
wird uns folglich ein aber man sieht sie
aber beide ja irgendwo ich auch mal ein
bisschen getreten weg und märz soll das
abteil
nein also mal ganz im ernst jeder ist
natürlich noch mal schwarz gefahren
irgendwie und ich finde dieses argument
was sie jetzt gerade genannt ist aber
auch eher um überzeugen denn ich glaube
das was die meisten leute vom
schwarzwald abschreckt ist genau diese
peinlichkeit und natürlich auch die
tatsache 60 euro beraten zu müssen was
nicht so schön ist und die leute die
überhaupt in gefahr sind mal wirklich
ernstlich vor gericht gestellt und
verurteilt zu werden das sind ja nur die
notorischen schwarze aber um drei mal
habe ich zu werden muss man
deutlich öfter als dreimal schwarz
machen es sei denn man das ein echter
pechvogel und die also das sind ja trotz
allem nur relativ wenige wenn man es mal
auf die insgesamt fahrgastaufkommen
hochrechnet und die kaufen also auch mit
also nicht sicherlich nicht einfallen
aber doch in vielen fällen weil sie
einfach die kohle nicht haben bei zeit
irgendwie armen schlucker sind das ist
dann ja noch neben
wir haben jetzt eben so ein bisschen
pragmatisch argumentiert einfach
ressourcen usw
es gibt natürlich auch noch die etwas
ideologischer argumentation dass man
sagt also das wird hier quasi armut
kriminalisiert ja auch das kann man ja
zumindest mal so ins feld führen ja das
finde ich auch richtig wobei ich gesagt
ich finde das argument ein bisschen kurz
gegriffen
denn es sind eben nicht nur sonne fällt
das manchmal auch mal sagen also wir
sind eben auch leute die keinen bock
haben ja nicht dafür blechen wollen die
die kohle natürlich hätten für uns und
für sonst was ausgeben ja aber nicht
sich nicht in der lage sehen die in den
örtlichen den nahverkehr zu unterstützen
was ich übrigens leon war ja und ich
meine damen system der sozialen
sicherung leute können hartz 4
beantragen da werden alle möglichen
bedarf des lebens auch zum beispiel die
tatsache dass man gelegentlich bahn
fahren muss ich immer eingepreist einen
hartz-iv-satz ist also sicherlich jetzt
nicht gerechtfertig zu sagen ja gut wenn
man das geld nicht hat dann hat man sich
einfach nicht aber trotzdem so alles in
allem unwerth gehalt schaden für die
gesellschaft auch auf der einen seite
und und eben ressourcen die da rein
fließen bei der strafverfolgung der
justiz und dem vollzug auf der anderen
seite scheint mir doch irgendwie in der
gesamtabwägung viel dafür zu sprechen zu
sagen ordnungswidrigkeiten tatbestand
der täter ist hier auch wichtig es wird
übrigens demnächst auch wieder eine
diskussion geben das nur als kleine
hinweis in berlin am 5
februar macht das die landesvertretung
in hamburg in berlin macht dann eine
diskussionsveranstaltung das wird da
auch breit diskutiert ist auch der nrw
justizminister
wiesenbach dabei also der sozusagen vor
im herbst also ein bisschen angestoßen
hat dieser aktuelle debatte also etwas
worüber man gut streiten kann
aber wo ich auch dafür plädieren würde
dass man sich mein herz greift und da
vielleicht auch eine änderung bei
herbeiführt weil er alles in allem
tatsächlich das jetzt mal geboten mir
habe ich übrigens klitzekleiner
historischer exkurs an der stelle der
aber vielleicht sich ganz schön das
thema einfügt das war ja lange zeit auch
total umstritten ob schwarzfahren
überhaupt nach diesem paragrafen
strafbar ist
genau das ist auch eine schöne ein
schöner schlenker weil es ging ums
erschleichen naja also erschleichen von
leistungen hast du schon gehört bestand
ja und ist nach allgemeinem
sprachgebrauch impliziert dass boccia
schleichen ja irgendwie dass man sich
mit einer gewissen heimlichkeit an einer
kontrolle vielleicht vorbei drückt oder
ähnliches und das ist ja überhaupt nicht
der fall
leute die keine fahrkarte am steigen
ganz genauso in die bahn ein wie leute
die eine haben das system nicht an der
nasenspitze anzusehen und und die
verhalten sich nicht anders also davon
einmal schleichend zu reden ist
eigentlich schwierig das ist dann aber
doch letzten endes von der
rechtsprechung finde ich nicht
selbstverständlicher weise aber es ist
abgesegnet worden
richtig und also wirklich vor dem
hintergrund dass wenn man die bezüge
besteigt oder dem bus besteigt dann
drückt man damit auch sein
einverständnis aus dass das nur unter
den bedingungen erfolgt die von dem
nahverkehr eben aufgegeben sind es gab
ja auch ganz kuriose fälle von polit
aktivisten die sich dann explizit auf
die das t shirt oder die akn geschrieben
haben ich fahre schwarz also damit
überhaupt gar keinen zweifel auf dass
sogar das ganze gegenteil eines
erschleichens ja das ist sogar ein
empfang mit hinausschreien
seht her ich beachte es eben gerade aber
soweit ich jetzt gesehen habe
jedenfalls gab es ja in hessen auf einen
fall wo das dann auch abgebügelt wurde
und gesagt wurde
hier findet tatsächlich eine
schleichende statt
dementsprechend inzwischen also dass nur
so als kleinen schlenker das ist
deswegen auch total gefestigter
rechtsprechung lasse
dann ein fall ist ein schleichender
leistung darstellt aber ob es das dann
auch in der zukunft noch tun soll
darüber könnte man durchaus mal
nachdenken auch dieses wäre eine sache
die sich ja vielleicht die spd mal
überlegen könnte für die nächste große
koalition auf die und wie gesagt
angestoßen wurde es vom nrw
justizminister in wiesenbach und die snc
ungarn cdu zum nächsten thema zum
nächsten thema wir hatten schon einmal
über das netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz
gesprochen in folge nummer sechs unter
schon viel von dem für und wieder
aufgearbeitet aber die debatte hält das
land weiterhin in atem
und es sind auch ein paar haben sich
auch ein paar zusätzliche entwicklungen
ergeben wie nicht anders zu erwarten zum
beispiel der tweet von alois seidl über
den wir damals in der sendung gesprochen
hatten mit denen mit den pöbelnden
migranten mops oder so ähnlich ist
wiederhergestellt worden
interessanterweise wir hatten ja auch
damals gesagt dass wir den zwei
unschönen fanden aber nicht glauben das
ist eine straftat darstellt dass sie
twitter jetzt offenbar ähnlich da hat
sich allerdings auch erst ein anwalt
einschalten müssen
und das ist natürlich irgendwie ehrlich
das ist nicht so praktikabel für die
meisten leute lebend wieder gelöscht
werden
umgekehrt auch dann finde ich ganz
lustige anekdote in dem kontext ein
tweet von heiko maas ein sieben jahre
alter tweet von heiko maas hat
offensichtlich jemand schon sozusagen
auf wiedervorlage gelegt zum
inkrafttreten des netz.de und dann wohl
gemeldet wurde gelöst indem er thilo
sarrazin einen idioten genannt hat ja
auch da kann man natürlich idiot ist
jetzt kein so nette bezeichnung und ist
es wirklich eine strafbare beleidigung
naja man weiß dass alles nicht so genau
er ist auf jeden fall ganz lustig dass
ausgerechnet hier von den ziehvater das
netz dann selbst ein post gelegt worden
ist und ja also verschiedene weitere
müssen wir jetzt nicht alles aufzählen
leute sind gesperrt und auch wieder
entsperrt worden und die diskussion tobt
und war ziemlich emotional geführt und
zu den rechtlichen aspekten dessen haben
wir ja hier in der sendung schon manches
gesagt ich persönlich würde dem ganzen
eine chance geben wollen und abwarten
wie es sich jetzt über die nächsten
monate entwickelt und jedenfalls man
muss sicherlich nicht das netz ag in
allen punkten super finden das tue ich
selber auch nicht
aber die tatsache dass vorher wirklich
vieles im argen lag ja dass die großen
internetkonzerne zum einen nach total
undurchsichtigen kriterien gelöscht oder
nicht gelöst haben und zweitens auch vor
allen dingen eben nicht gelöscht haben
in aller regel ja das ist glaube ich
wirklich schwer zu leugnen ja und wer
daran noch letzte zweifel haben sollte
weil es vielleicht einfach aus seinem
persönlichen erleben so nie mitbekommen
hat oder wer sich vielleicht auch denkt
dass generell diese ganze debatte doch
irgendwie ein bisschen albern sei und
dass man da doch wohl auch einfach
drüber stehen könnte wenn man irgendwie
auftreten giftzwerg angepackt wird ja
dem möchte ich dass nun gleich folgende
interview besonders dringend ans herz
legen
das ist mit richard gutjahr den werde
ich auch gleich noch vorstellen und also
wir haben das interview würde ich an der
stelle immer dazu sagen vorab
aufgezeichnet und schneiden dass jetzt
gleich in die sendung ein
und ja ich hätte hat eben wirklich mal
aus der innensicht erleben müssen wie
das ist wenn man opfer einer
regelrechten hass kampagne im netz so
wird und er hat auch anderthalb jahre so
lange dauert es inzwischen versucht die
netzwerke dazu zu bewegen die gegen ihn
gerichteten kommentare zu löschen
größtenteils ohne erfolg und er kann
einmal zählen ob sich das jetzt unter
dem netz tgm wie gewässert hat in diesem
sinne hier kommt richard gutjahr
richard ist journalist und blogger und
internet pionier kann man glaube ich
sagen es im fernsehen zu sehen er hat so
ziemlich alle großen deutschen zeitungen
schon zu verschiedenen anlässen
geschrieben
das alles ist aber nicht der grund warum
wir ihnen heute in der sendung haben
jedenfalls nicht so unmittelbar sondern
war auch gezwungen ein jurastudium einem
schnellverfahren zu nicht laufen könnte
man sagen ja ist nämlich selber in ganz
massiver weise opfer von hate speech wie
man so sagt also hass kommentaren im
internet geworden
nicht mal hier und da wie das jedem
journalisten geht dass man mal irgendwo
ein gehässigen kommentare kriegt sondern
da hat sich also eine ganze troll ami
gegen ihn stellung gebracht und das hört
sich ein bisschen lustig an ist aber
leider in der praxis wirklich alles
andere als lustig und aufgrund dessen
es sei eben auch jemand der einfach mal
sehr guten praktischen einblick darin
geben kann wie die sozialen netzwerke
die polizei und staatsanwaltschaft und
die gerichte bisher mit solchen fällen
umgegangen sind und ob sich dadurch
möglich dass netzte gehe jetzt etwas zum
besseren geändert hat ja herzlich
willkommen liebe richard vielen dank für
die einladung
kannst du uns vielleicht erstmal in
kurzen worten erzählen wie es überhaupt
dazu gekommen dass das sowieso zur
zielscheibe verwirrte geister wurde ist
ja das kam buchstäblich über nacht ich
war in nizza im urlaub und das war der
französische nationalfeiertag der
vierzehnte juli vor zwei jahren
und da gab es ein großes feuerwerk
parade volksfeststimmung entlang der
strandpromenade und meine familie und
ich haben uns ein hotel genommen weil
wir halten das feuerwerk sehen und
wollten einfach dort eben zusammen mit
den franzosen feiern und da kam dann
diese geschichte mit diesem lkw der da
vor unseren fans ein balkonfenster
sozusagen vorbeifuhr das problem habe
meine familie war gerade unten balance
kaufen mit stand oben hat eigentlich
nichts ahnen sozusagen meine familie
gefilmt und da kamen dann sozusagen der
lkw um die ecke familie ist nichts
passiert er kam mit einem schock davon
und ja dann dann bin ich halt sozusagen
ein reporter modus um geschwitzt und hab
dann nachdem ich meine familie sozusagen
einigermaßen sicherheit wenn dann gesagt
hat muss jetzt arbeiten wollen was diese
attentate ist durch die menschenmenge
gefügt der eckelmann einer hat sich also
ich möchte das jetzt auch nicht so
witzig da stelle ich versuche ja
sozusagen selber irgendwie auch mit
diesen erlebnissen fertig zu denn war
nicht so schön ich habe zum ersten mal
menschen sterben sehen und schreie und
so weiter die verfolgen dann natürlich
dann auch noch
ein paar tage länger ja dann kam ein
zweites wie soll man sagen tragisches
unglück hinzu ich war dann wieder die
woche drauf also aus dem urlaub zurück
in münchen ich habe da ganz normal
gearbeitet wie ich das schon seit 15
jahren tue und deswegen das ist nicht
verwunderlich dass ich jetzt zufällig in
münchen war als dort plötzlich meine
tochter anrief und gesagt hat papa bei
uns im olympia einkaufszentrum wird
geschossen
und da gab es halt noch nicht wie viele
viele offiziellen meldungen darüber ich
war in sorge sofort natürlich zu meiner
tochter hingefahren und auch dort war es
dann tatsächlich so dass ich für die ard
dann hat als einer der ersten reporter
vor ort war und natürlich auch
berichtete
es ist mein job kann nicht anders und ja
aus diesem soll man sagen aus diesem
zufall oder aus dieser zeitlichen nähe
dieser wie soll ich sagen ja sonst
eigentlich völlig normalen tätigkeit der
ich seit 20 jahren nachgehen haben dann
ein paar menschen im netz gesagt
irgendwie das kann doch kein zufall
gewesen sein ich glaube die tatsache
dass meine frau jüdin ist hat so bei
manchen einfach wirklich so eine flagge
gehisst und gesagt aha da ist also der
mossad und irgendwelche jüdischen
verschwörungen irgendwie dahinter und ja
ab dem moment gab es dann kein halten
mehr im netz erhält könnte man ja sagen
noten gibt es immerhin das kann einmal
egal sein was die denken aber
tatsächlich kann dass das keineswegs
denn diese leute haben das ja nicht nur
im stillen kämmerlein gedacht sondern
eben auch großflächig verbreitet und
gestreut dass du also tatsächlich hinter
diesen anschlägen stunde ist wie ist das
konkret wie muss man sich das vorstellen
er ist beginnt ganz harmlos erst mal mit
so patricia oder den üblichen norden
üblichen shitstorm den wir alle als
journalisten kennen das fängt erst mal
wirklich relativ wie soll man sagen ja
normal also sowie halt so es ist ja auch
verständlich es ist eine sehr hoch
emotionalisierte zeitnah also gerade
mädchen war ja
er war ja panik nicht nur in der in der
bayerischen landeshauptstadt sondern
deutschlandweit haben die leute ja
plötzlich bei der polizei angerufen und
gesagt bei ihnen wird auch geschossen
und so also da das ist die menschliche
psyche wirklich faszinierend was was was
was da plötzlich in uns ausgelöst wird
alles ich glaube auch immer aus einer
wisse man sagen ja angst oder ohnmacht
die wir vielleicht verspüren in so einem
moment gehen dann wirklich die pferde
und die gäule mit uns durch und wenn man
dann eben zufällig noch ein internet
account hat und und und klattens
besseres zu tun hat dann setzt man sich
da halt hin und schreibt einfach eins zu
eins das was einem gerade durch den kopf
geht einfach ins netz
und und und das spornt dann wiederum
andere an und so entwickelt sich
sozusagen dann so eine spirale wo dann
plötzlich irgendwie alle versuchen sich
gegenseitig in ihrem wahnsinn zu
überbieten
und diese leute haben nicht einfach nur
theorien aufgestellt sondern sie sind
dann ja auch die rund was ist noch mal
ein schöner macht auch deiner familie
zuliebe grüttner also da wurden dann
glaube ich ebenfalls theorien
aufgestellt dass du deine frau oder dein
kind damit irgendwie was zu tun hätten
und es gab etliche videos auf youtube wo
das alles ausgebreitet wurde
wie hat sich das in deinem leben
beeinflusst es gibt kein anderes thema
mehr eigentlich ist seit seit diesen zu
diesen ersten ersten echten wo das dann
wirklich irgendwie aus sagt kontrolle
geriet wir haben am anfang erstmal
gedacht streisand effekt also bloß nicht
bloß nicht irgendwie drauf eingehen
aussitzen ruhe bewahren vielleicht auch
mit humor so diese theorien einfach
nehmen und darüber lachen
nach ein paar wenn das das hält man ein
paar tage aus ein paar wochen aber wenn
es dann mehrere monate andauert und man
darf nicht vergessen mit jedem neuen
terroranschlag
also ich erinnere zum beispiel eine
breitscheidplatz berlin der dass ich
dann halbes jahr später ereignet hat
waren wir wieder plötzlich dass das
thema nummer eins dass die terror
familie die dahinter steckt und das
reicht dann nur irgendwie ein eine
kleinigkeit dass dort irgendwann der
tagesschau ein 1 1 1 1 ein jüdischer
augenzeuge auftaucht dann wird gegoogelt
ob es irgendwelche zusammenhänge zu und
meiner familie gibt und wenn die dann
irgendwie etwas finden ich glaube in
diesem zusammenhang wurde mal
aufgestellt dass meine frau mal an
derselben universität irgendwie eine
rede gehalten hat wie wie der mensch der
tatarische aufgetreten ist dann dann ist
der beweis erbracht und andere das hirn
ausgeschaltet dann ist das so fakt ja
und dann dann dann verhärtet sich das in
den köpfen und von da an geht dann ganze
weihnachten neujahr und für die nächsten
zwei oder drei monaten monate der zirkus
dann wieder von vorne los und was würde
ich eine möglichkeit zu sagen ich
ignoriere das einfach oder ist das in
einer art und weise in ein leben
eingedrungen dass man jetzt also selbst
bei größter containers und innerer
gelassenheit das einfach nicht
ausblenden konnte als die die die täter
dann angefangen haben also meine familie
zu sezieren und sich auf allen sozialen
netzwerken sozusagen auch beispielsweise
meine tochter vorgenommen haben
da hörte der spaß dann wirklich auf die
polizei hatte mir sowieso schon geraten
dass wir irgendwie die wohnung verlassen
und irgendwo wo erst mal für ein paar
wochen woanders hinziehen dass sich das
dass man wieder beruhigt also schwer
einzuschätzen was man da macht wie
gesagt meine tochter die ist jetzt kein
journalist steht jetzt nicht im
öffentlichen leben und so weiter und und
da hab ich gesagt hier hier hier ist die
rote linie und jetzt muss ich anfangen
was zu unternehmen
nur um mal einen dieser kommentar ist
das ja alles sehr transparent gemacht
und auch auf seiner homepage ausführlich
referiert vorzulesen damit wieder eine
vorstellung davon haben was da
tatsächlich abgeht seine heutige drecks
familie interessiert niemanden er ist
ein dreckiger und der geheimdienst als
perfekt und seine kinder werden nicht
besser sein ja das ist so der sound der
sich hier
hindurch zieht also das ist wirklich
harter tobak und etwas was man sich
nicht gefallen lassen muss und nun
schlange vielleicht ein bisschen den
bogen zu der juristischen aufarbeitung
dieser ganzen geschichte denn man hört
ja immer im zusammenhang mit dem letzter
gehen das stimmt ja mit abstrichen im
detail auch dass das netz die eigentlich
keine materie rechtliche neuregelung
schafft sondern dass diese entsprechende
äußerung auch bisher schon strafbar
waren und das ist einfach nur darum
ginge ein vollzugsdefizit zu beseitigen
wie hast du dieses vollzugsdefizit denn
erlebt in deinen versuchen den hass
gegen dich im netz zurückzudrängen
also trotz hunderten anmoderation muss
ich eines vorweg schicken ich bin
wirklich kein jurist ja ich bin der
komplette leihe ich habe jetzt zwei zwei
anwälte die mich beraten strafrechtlich
und zivilrechtlich
ich habe also wie soll man sagen jetzt
so ein bisschen einblick bekommen und
habe mich immer rückversichert wenn ich
gefragt hat das kann nicht sein und dann
sagen die doch doch das ist alles in
ordnung so und was habe ich erlebt im
grunde genommen gar nicht viel neues
außer dass das netz also wie soll man
sagen
die gesetze sind alle da dann braucht
man kein kein neues ja also von wegen
dieses gerede von wegen internet
rechtsfreier raum das ist das bullshit
alles was mir angetan worden ist meiner
familie meiner tochter und allen
freunden und jeden der da mit
reingezogen worden ist das steht alles
unter strafe kann man nachlesen ist es
nicht es ist nicht mehr so da ist unser
grundgesetz sogar schon ziemlich
ziemlich also auch für die digitale welt
sozusagen eins zu eins umsetzbar problem
ist nur das tempo und die gravität also
di di di di di di sehr schwere sozusagen
und die folgen die so etwas hat die
glaube ich sind in der justiz bei den
staatsanwälten vor allem aber auch bei
den richtern nicht angekommen was mir
oft begegnet ist ist das beispielsweise
einen wunsch meine familie irgendwie im
kz zu vergasen
im grunde genommen so ähnlich geld
sanktioniert wird wie als hätte ich auf
der straße jemanden den vogel gezeigt ja
also ich glaube was das was die dd dd
die justiz noch nicht so richtig kapiert
hat ist sagen wir mal anders ich hatte
irgendwie das gefühl nicht nur anhand
der strafhöhe sondern ich habe ja auch
mit sehr vielen richtern und
staatsanwälten dann auch mal telefoniert
ich hatte das gefühl die meinen immer
noch das ist ja nur im internet
also das ist sozusagen nur virtuell das
ist ja nicht das reale leben sondern das
reale leben findet noch immer auf der
straße statt an der straßenkreuzung oder
wenn ich was in der zeitung drucke oder
ein buch heraus gebe da da sind die dann
besonders sagen sage ja das ist schlimm
im internet das versendet sich irgendwie
so das problem ist genau umgekehrt mich
das nicht es bleibt ein stigma quasi im
leben eines menschen denken sie einmal
eine tochter wenn die sich irgendwann
mal bewerben möchte für einen job und
und und diese hater schaffen ist dass
die ersten fünf seiten bei google
einfach quasi nur nur irgendwelchen
schwachsinn über sie verbreiten das
zeichnet dieses mädchen in jungen jahren
für ihr leben
und ja wenn dann jemand halt mit 280
euro davon kommt wenn er so etwas wenn
er wenn er eine gewerk patrone in meiner
tochter also auf die facebook-seite pint
und und sagt hier auch eine lösung für
dich dann dann muss ich ehrlich gesagt
sagen
wissen sie ich habe ja auch ein paar
feinde und ein paar menschen die ich
nicht mag in meinem leben
also nehme ich doch mal nehme ich doch
mal ein bisschen geld geld in die hand
und und verbreite einfach müll über
meine gegner weil kost ja nicht so viel
also es ist ehrlich gesagt so ein
bisschen unverständlich dass das zwar
immer in den in den nachrichten immer
heißt ja und wir müssen da hat es darf
kein rechtsfreier raum sein ja die ja
aber was ich in den letzten eineinhalb
jahren erlebt haben muss ich ehrlich
gesagt sagen irgendwie also eigentlich
haben die hater ja recht kostet ja
nichts
in wie vielen fällen ist
denn überhaupt gelungen die verfasser
dieser nachrichten tatsächlich zu
ermitteln
und überhaupt irgendwie eine anklage
gegen die zu führen also jetzt mache ich
erwarte jetzt keine exakten zahlen aber
mehr so allgemein also sind ist das sagt
es meistens geklappt oder war dass er
diese hält eine ausnahme in vielen
fällen muss man gar nicht ermitteln die
schreiben unter ihren vollen namen
ich kann mir von meinem von diesen von
diesen menschen anschauen
die meine meine familie irgendwie meine
familie den tod wünschen und also den
facebook kommentar den sie gerade
vorgelesen hatten vorher den hatte ein
familienvater kann man drauf klicken
kann man sich seine urlaubsfotos
anschauen und seine eigenen töchter
anschauen
da muss man dann muss man gar nicht
großartig irgendwie csi miami sein und
datenforensiker um die db und die
identitäten festzustellen das ist genau
das was mich ja über meinen eigenen
persönlichen man sagen schicksal hinaus
noch so fertig macht dass er wissen ich
bin ja schon viel viel gewohnt in meinem
leben das ist gar nicht mal so das was
mich schmerzt dass die schmerzt ist dass
das in der gesellschaft also in unserer
in unserer hier in deutschland möglich
ist und dass die sich so sicher fühlen
dass sie dafür nicht belangt werden weil
sonst würden die ja aufpassen uns würden
sie sich auch mehr mühe geben ihre
spuren zu verwischen nein die fühlen
sich unantastbar und deswegen deswegen
haben sie es gar nicht nötig da
irgendwie einen untergrund zu gehen und
das ehrlich gesagt das macht mir angst
weil das ist ein klares zeichen dafür
dass das internet wohl sehr wohl ein
rechtsfreier raum ist und man ist eben
nicht recht diejenigen die das immer
behaupten nämlich der innenminister und
ausgerechnet der justizminister sind
sind hier nicht wieso man sagen
irgendwer sondern so wenn also die sind
dann müssen sich da die kritik finde ich
umgekehrt schon auch gefallen lassen und
sagen ja wie ist das eigentlich möglich
gibt es nun diese gesetze in unserem
land oder gibt es sie nicht und
das hat also auch keinen effekt dahin
gehend gehabt man könnte sich ja
vorstellen beispielsweise das werden
sich herumspricht dass sind ja mitunter
solche community viele leute auch ein
bisschen miteinander in kontakt stehen
wenn sich herumspricht da der gut ja ja
stellt hier konsequent strafanzeigen und
der eine oder andere wird dann
tatsächlich ermittelt und und angeklagt
und wegen verurteilung wenn auch jetzt
also in dem gerade zitierten falls wahr
zu sein in der sehr geringen summe aber
trotzdem verurteilt
man könnte sich auch vorstellen wenn man
so ein bisschen aus der anonymität des
oder oder scheinbaren anonymität des
internet rolf ausgezehrt und vor gericht
gestellt wird dass das eindruck
hinterlässt und dass es dann eben
vielleicht den effekt hätte das die
ganze sache so langsam abklingt aber das
war entnehme ich dem vortrag nicht so
ganz im gegenteil
doch dann war ruhe mit dem wissen das
ich heute habe ich meine ich war damals
auch ein bisschen naiv vor eineinhalb
jahren ich dachte irgendwie tatsächlich
bloß nicht bloß nicht in erscheinung
treten bloß nicht auffallen bloß nichts
machen nein ich hätte ich hätte viel
früher tatsächlich damit beginnen müssen
konsequent ich hätte mir viel früher
anwälte nehmen müssen ich hätte viel
früher also mit voller härte mir die
wortführer herausgreifen und und die mit
allem was ich habe einfach einfach nach
nachgehen müssen erst durch meine
untätigkeit durch meine blauäugigkeit
durch meine hoffnung und bitte hört von
alleine auf oder jetzt nicht nicht in
erscheinung treten nicht laut
aussprechen ich bin sogar für mehrere
wochen ab sechs oder sieben wochen
komplett kein einziger tritt kann
einziger facebook post das ist halt
jemanden wie wir verdammt schwer das ist
die höchststrafe aber aber es hat nichts
gebracht nein heute weiß ich schau dir
genau an so zu sagen wer sind die
wortführer in diesem spiel und und wenn
sie sich strafbar machen dann dann dann
geh geh mit allen rechtlichen mitteln
denen denen nach weil weil wissen sie
ich mache das ja nicht um da irgend
jemanden zu schaden oder um um mir zu
helfen ich mache ich mache das oder mir
geht es auch gar nicht um die person
mir geht es um alle anderen die diesen
scheiß licon
sharon und tritten sind sie müssen sich
das vorstellen das ist ein duell auf
einer öffentlichen bühne und und die die
meisten davon 98 der zuschauer sind
unbeteiligt holen sich popcorn und und
sagen ja mal schauen wie das ausgeht
wenn wenn wenn wenn du dich nicht wärs
wenn du da nicht dagegen hältst dann ist
das ein ganz klares signal irgendwie mit
na ja was machen genau geht ja und ich
finde also noch haben für diesen
rechtsstaat und ich finde er hat sehr
viele errungenschaften über die letzten
jahrhunderte uns uns uns erkämpft und
erwacht und ich glaube es wäre darum zu
kämpfen und dann noch ein weiterer
wichtiger aspekt jetzt ging es erstmal
so um die strafrechtliche seite
die zivilrechtliche ebene also sprich
dass man auf die plattformen zugeht und
denen sagt passt mal auf wie ihr seid
verpflichtet diesen oder jenen
kommentare zu löschen
tut das mit das ist diesen versuch es ja
durchaus auch unternommen
wie waren deine erfahrung
also das war den komplett wurscht und
das ist dass das dass das fand ich
beschämend ehrlich gesagt weil sie
müssen sich vorstellen an dem morgen des
terrorangriffs von nizza war ich noch
bei google als referent eingeladen in
münchen und habe dort einen vortrag
gehalten über deutschland über
nazi-deutschland und über die verbrechen
die wir hier in diesem land begangen
haben den vertrag habe ich deshalb
gehalten weil eine internationale
gruppe von programmierern die jetzt bei
google sozusagen neu eingeführt worden
sind
die sollten alle länder kennenlernen und
auch die verantwortung die sie haben
sozusagen auch im austausch mit mit mit
den einzelnen menschen und deren deren
gesellschaften auch lernen slater sozial
engagierte kampagne mit dass google ja
gerne für richtig so und dafür hat man
mich eingeladen am am abend bin ich in
nizza gewesen
wie gesagt im urlaub dann ich habe das
jetzt sozusagen auf dem weg zum
flughafen habe ich die noch besucht und
und nur eine woche später telefoniere
ich also genau mit den leuten die mich
noch so nett hofiert und eingeladen
hatten in ihr neues ihrer neuen zahlen
die center in münchen und sagt leute
schaut doch mal an was auf eurer
plattform youtube gerade mit meiner
familie und mir gemacht wird helft mir
gesagt ja tut uns leid aber freedom of
speech usw
wir haben da können wir nichts machen
das ist amerikanisches recht so was
natürlich völlig absurd und auch
unzutreffend ist also denn jedenfalls in
deutschland müssen sie sich ja schon an
deutsches recht halten
also es wurde gar nichts gelöscht
fragezeichen oder war es schon so dass
dann in einzelfällen auch mal dinge
gelöscht wurden aber eben sehr vieles
stehen blieb nicht wegen verleumdung
hate crimes oder derlei dinge also 0
die arbeit hätte ich mir also sparen
können ist ja auch ein zwei tage bis man
das mal so 60 videos sozusagen also nach
dem ganz komplexe prozedur und das geht
eben nicht mal eben schnell sondern da
muss man sich wirklich für jedes
einzelne video das man meldet also gut
eine viertelstunde 20 minuten zeit
nehmen egal habe ich hätte ich mir
sparen können womit bisschen
funktioniert hat war das urheberrecht
also die haben zum beispiel alle
irgendwie mein video verwendet dass ich
ja in der nacht für die ard dann
freigegeben habe aber sonst niemanden
eigentlich die erlaubnis gegeben habe
dieses video zu verwenden
und da konnte ich also dann zum beispiel
copyright das ist ja eigentlich auch
waren wird signal dass dieser
genau das dass der geahndet wird oder
dass über den hebel dann schnell
funktioniert aber über sagen eigentlich
die gravierenden punkt ist ja ist ja
völlig klar erinnern sie sich an die an
die an die debatten die youtube
natürlich mit der musikindustrie und die
kriege ausfechten musste da da da sind
die ganz schnell in irgendwelchen
millionen für forderungen wird wegen
wegen urheberrechtsverstößen und so
weiter und da sind die trainiert das
heißt also auf dieser auf dieser verse
trifft man sie tatsächlich weil sie
wissen dass könnte geld kosten
und dafür sind sie auch in den usa
übrigens haftbar
also das ist tatsächlich so zu sagen so
etwas da da passen die auf wie wie kaum
etwas anderes hat auch nur zwei stunden
gedauert bis dann so ein video entfernt
war also von der meldung bis zum
entfernen und zwar entfernen meine ich
nicht nur im geo blocking also in dem
landwind deutschland netz.de jetzt
einfach nur unsichtbar trotzdem immer
noch überall in der welt in österreich
und der schweiz sind so zu sehen
nein das haben die dann richtig gesperrt
geblockt löschen tun sie nix aber
zumindest weltweit gesperrt
ja aber dann haben sie es halt auch
wieder frei gestellt indem sie sozusagen
parallel dazu meinen kontrahenten dann
meinen namen also meine e-mail und meine
postanschrift geschickt haben und gesagt
haben ein ich euch doch mal darüber
wegen wegen wegen copyright verstößt
untereinander dass wir lassen sie lassen
nehmen sie jetzt wieder online weil der
andere gesagt hat er hat dann nicht
verstoßen und ab jetzt bitte einig ihr
euch untereinander das ist das prozedere
bis zum heutigen tag das war in dem fall
dann auch noch mal zusätzlich
schmerzlichen weil die leute dann auf
diese weise auch noch an deine e mail
adresse gelangt sind wenn ich und raten
sie mal was sie dann gemacht haben mit
dieser e mail adresse ich kann es mir
ungefähr vorstellen
na klar ich habe den erst mal erst mal
haben sie erfahren dass ich sie quasi
angeschwärzt hat punkt eins und dann
sozusagen als sie gemerkt haben dass
youtube aber das video trotzdem nicht
entfernt sondern wieder scharf schaltet
war das ein doppelter sieg für die weil
sie gemerkt haben
er hat es probiert und er ist
gescheitert und und und dann gehts erst
richtig los und jetzt haben die ihre e
mail adresse und ihre postanschrift und
ja dann dann dann ging es halt weit in
die nächste runde
ja also das ist glaube ich wirklich mal
so ein prototypisches beispiel dafür um
vielleicht auch allen hörern die sich
bisher bei der letzten debatte oft
gedacht haben mein gott leute stellt
euch doch nicht so an über irgendeinen
punkigen kommentar von einem giftzwerg
auf da kann man ja auch mal drüber
stehen
klar solange das ein parlament als
stimmt das auch aber wenn man eben ein
solcher weise wirklich überzogen wird
von schmähungen und verleumdungen usw
dann greift das wirklich erheblich in
das eigene leben ein und das letzte
gesetz in kraft das oder vielleicht auch
schon im zuge der also es kündigte sich
ja anders kommen würde gibt seit die
wahrnehmung dass das seitdem besser
funktioniert wenn du jetzt eigentlich
ihre videos oder oder kommentare oder
ähnliches meldet dass die er entfernt
werden oder wird das kannst das nicht
beobachten doch es hatte quasi mittag 1
natürlich einen einen gewaltigen wie
soll man sagen effekt gehabt
auf einmal sind also die die die mails
meiner meine anwälte dort tatsächlich
gelesen worden bis dato haben wir immer
zurückbekommen
unsere form mail bitte wenden sie sich
an youtube in amerika und und da wurde
dann irgendwie so ein abwimmeln link hin
also eingeschickt der genau zu dieser
seite führte die ich als allererstes
probiert hatte ja das muss man dazu
sagen dass bisher waren die nicht
verpflichtet im empfangs
bevollmächtigten in deutschland zu haben
und jetzt eben schon und das übrigens
ist auch einen teil des netz dgb bei dem
eigentlich alle übereinstimmen dass es
sinnvoll ist also andere dinge werden ja
kritisiert
auch weil man eben sagte das ist streng
die meinungsfreiheit ein oder es droht
dann die gefahr des overclocking tut sie
ja vielleicht auch tatsächlich in
anderen konstellationen arbeiten diesen
diesen zustand bevollmächtigten zu haben
dass man also überhaupt erst mal
drankommt und die netzwerke das ist
sagt eigentlich jeder total sinnvoll was
hast du super schreck war in diesem
zusammenhang und das beleuchtungs ja
gerade so zu sagen hier den positiven
effekt dass netz dg was muss es ja
wirklich auf der zunge zergehen lassen
musste der erste also nachdem ich quasi
alle meine anzeigen gemacht habe und
meine anwälte eingeschaltet habe und
weiter die erste reaktion sozusagen die
ich behördlich bekommen habe kam von der
regierung von mittelfranken
sehr geehrter herr gut ja wir sind
bayernweit zuständige aufsichtsbehörde
für die anbieterkennzeichnung das tmg
telemediengesetzes und eine überprüfung
ihrer internetseite hat ergeben das
impressum des internetauftritts nicht
alle gemäß § 5 tmg erforderlichen
angaben gemacht worden sind wir müssen
sich das so vorstellen ja die polizei
einerseits zeigt sich tatsächlich sehr
besorgt mir gegenüber verlangt von mir
dass ich also quasi alle
sicherheitsvorkehrungen treffen stellt
mir sogar den staatsschutz zur seite
weil sie befürchten dass irgendwelche
rechtsradikalen irgendwie meine jüdische
familie irgendwie zu nahe kommt und das
kriege ich also has offizielles
schreiben dann umgekehrt sozusagen die
abmahnung weil ich meine wohnanschrift
aus dem impressum genommen habe und dass
google facebook und co jetzt wenigstens
auch eine impressumspflicht haben
beziehungsweise einen ansprechpartner in
dem man sich hier in deutschland wenden
kann
das ist nun finde ich vor diesem
hintergrund doch wenigstens mal eine
errungenschaft ja das ist natürlich
etwas wie hohn wirken wenn man dann als
erstes also klar die impressumspflicht
ergibt dass man muss da eine
kontaktadresse als betreiber einer
homepage hinterlassen
aber kann man jetzt allerdings sagen in
deinem verletzt ist prezi andere belange
gegeben und die man sich
behördlicherseits vielleicht erst mal
kümmern können
nun ja also aber jetzt jedenfalls sagen
dass vielleicht gerade noch mal zum
abschluss und ich würde sagen denn
wenn wir die geschichte auch so ungefähr
besprochen seitdem letzte gerne zum 1 es
gibt diesen zustand vor mächtigen und
ist jetzt auch eher so dass also es ist
so dass denken jetzt auch schneller
gelöscht werden in seiner wahrnehmung
fünf tage hat das gedauert wir haben auf
einen schlag war sie ist so viele videos
in anführungszeichen unsichtbar mehr
passiert nicht für deutschland
unsichtbar machen können wie die ganzen
eineinhalb jahre zuvor nicht das ist ein
tropfen auf dem heißen stein aber es ist
es wichtig also dafür bin ich ehrlich
gesagt da bin ich nicht böse und auch
kein kritiker das netz dgs ich würde
aber ich finds schade dass es überhaupt
so zu sagen dieses gesetz geben muss
denn freedom of speech und und
meinungsfreiheit hin oder her kein kein
keine zeitung kein verlag muss ja
sondern sagen auch die publikation
pflicht oder solltet ihr gibt es ja
nicht ja wenn die faz sagt irgendwie ja
das ist zwar vom grundgesetz gedeckt wir
wollen es aber trotzdem nicht drucken
dann drucken sie nicht punkt so und das
heißt also die nets netz facebook google
und so weiter könnte sehr könnten sehr
wohl eigene haus regeln aufstellen die
genauso amerika es gibt ja diese
facebook community standards nur das ist
eben an der durchsetzung die relativen
konsequent verläuft oder oder auch
teilweise ja ja das stimmt nicht ganz
also die die haus standard sozusagen
erlauben zum beispiel hakenkreuze oder
sie erlauben auch zum beispiel jemanden
ins kz zu wünschen dass ist durch deren
community durchaus gedeckt also dann
wenn du das offiziell meldest auch mit
den juristen ich habe ja auch mit den
google juristen zu tun gehabt sagen tut
uns leid das ist durch unsere ist immer
noch gedeckt durch unsere standards also
insofern die könnte man ja mal ganz
unabhängig davon so zu sagen was was was
ginge auch nach dem amerikanischen recht
könnte man sagen ja wir wollen diese
kultur einfach nicht auf unserer seite
so und die dann können und warum das
nicht gemacht wird da
da kann man jetzt theorien darüber
aufstellen die die google deutschland
wird es auch nicht sagen können weil
dazu sind nicht befugt
aber dass es so zu sagen so etwas wo ich
glaube da muss man die in die pflicht
nehmen das ist mit dem netz geht zum
teil geschehen insofern noch einmal ich
kann nicht ich kann nichts böses aber
auch nichts gutes über das netz gehen
diesem zusammenhang sagen außer dass sie
etwas halt tun was eigentlich
selbstverständlich sein sollte dass wenn
man so eine macht und so einfluss und so
eine reichweite hat dass man dann auch
eine gewisse verantwortung hat vor allem
vor allem gegenüber unbeteiligten oder
den opfern
ja ich glaube das sind wunderbare worte
zum abschluss vielen vielen dank für
dieses gespräch was glaube ich wirklich
mal ganz plastisch vermittelt hat wie
unschönes anderen kann die meisten
menschen
glücklicherweise finden sich nicht in
der lage so sehr zur zielscheibe zu
werden wie das bei richard gutjahr der
fall war
aber es kann eben passieren und dann hat
das schon durchaus einen sinn dass es
eben auch gesetze zur entfernung solcher
kommentare gibt
ja lieber richard gutjahr vielen dank
für das gespräch
der dankeschön grüße an alle hörer ja
das war der richard wir ab und sagte ich
gefallen und sind damit auch schon fast
am ende der sendung angelangt aber nur
fast denn ihr wisst ihr was immer zu
guter letzt kommt das gerechte urteil
mit einem sache halt denen viele
wahrscheinlich noch nachvollziehen kann
es geht nämlich um eine hausarbeit der
übung im bürgerlichen recht für
fortgeschrittene also genau ein fall
eines jurastudenten der er sich
ungerecht behandelt gefühlt hat und da
ging vor das verwaltungsgericht ansbach
gezogen so und was war passiert er hatte
eben diese übung im bürgerlichen recht
für fortgeschrittene in einer
[Musik]
semesterferien geschrieben sich
offensichtlich doch einige mühe geben
denn er hat die die vorgegebene maximale
seitenzahl von 20 seiten überschritten
und zwar in diesem sommer also formal ja
gerade nicht naja 20 seiten abgegeben
aber wie sich vielleicht der eine oder
andere von euch noch aus studienzeiten
erinnern kann gibt es verschiedene
tricks die man manchmal zur anwendung
bringt um den eigenen texten kurz darauf
einzulassen also eigentlich ist richtig
er hat einfach den seitenrand verkürzt
also der ist natürlich ganz genau wir
erinnern uns alle sie vorgegeben ja
mitunter vier zentimetern am rand und so
weiter ein schrifttype mannheims niveau
min
und das hat er einfach mal sich darüber
hinweggesetzt als er gemerkt hat dass er
irgendwie mit mit seiner ganzen wissens
fülle da mit diesem platz nicht auskommt
und hat einfach den seitenrand
verkleinert hat gehofft dass merck
niemand aber dem professor kam es gleich
spanisch vor hat nachgerechnet die
textmenge umgerechnet und hat gesehen
dass der student nicht 20 seiten abgeben
hat sondern tatsächlich 23 sein und dann
ist etwas passiert was ich jetzt und wie
auch nicht sehr selbstverständlich
findet offensichtlich waren auf diesen
23 seiten nicht unfassbar viel gehalt
von es dabei ich habe eigentlich immer
gedacht dass wenn man nicht zu sagen hat
dann tut man es auch auf möglichst wenig
sind halten ja aber was auch wenn ich
mehr zeit gehabt hätte hätte ich mich
kurz gefasst also sein mal darunter auch
eine kunst die eigenen gedanken zu
bündeln absolut anders erleben wir jeden
tag beteiligt aber was macht also der
prob also er bewertet die in die
hausarbeit und macht ein abzug für jede
überflüssige über diesen 20 liegen
das war seite genau und das sind waren
daneben drei seiten also drei punkte
abzug und da offensichtlich wenig
substanz in der haushalt schon zu finden
war war die gesamtnote tatsächlich 0
punkte muss man auch mal sagen
ihre prüfung in den sand gesetzt auf
null punkte waren nicht mehr und selbst
3 na gut
ja ja und da ging hat er geklagt müsste
es ja eigentlich ganz lustig denn
tatsächlich müsste man ja sagen also
wenn du jetzt erfolgte ist wer das
ergebnis unterm strich immer noch das
gleiche denn mit drei punkten ist man ja
bekanntlich auch durchgefallen er hat
das aber irgendwie noch mal ein bisschen
anders argumentiert er meinte eben naja
also irgendwie die bewertung sei
generell so nicht zulässig man hätte
irgendwie nur den teil bzw
er hat halt in abrede gestellt dass dann
nur drei dabei rausgekommen wäre wohl
darauf dass eigentlich recht klar gesagt
hat und hatte aber damit auch nicht so
ganz durch langen erfolg nehmen denn das
verwaltungsgericht ansbach hat gesagt
das alles liegt im bewertungsspielraum
des professor des professors und hat
sich auch der argumentation des dozenten
angeschlossenen der hat nämlich gesagt
dass die prägnante und konzentrierte
präsentation aller im sachverhalt
angelegten probleme auf einem begrenzten
platz ein wesentlicher teil der prüfung
ist ja also man muss auch schon bei
dieser prüfung unter beweis stellen dass
man das nicht nur inhaltlich pakt
sondern auch formell dass man sich kurz
erhalten kann dass man sich auf das
wesentliche konzentrieren kann
und auch das wird in einer
wissenschaftlichen arbeit abgefragt und
und wurde deswegen abgesegnet ich finde
ja persönlich auch noch also mal davon
abgesehen dass es offenbar was den
inhalt betrifft jetzt nicht so
berauschend gewesen ist immer in dem
zweiten teil wächst das war nicht schön
hin im zweiten teil hättest brauchbare
passagen gegeben hat dabei stets bemüht
wie ich finde auch noch deshalb das
gerechte urteil ganz ehrlich weil ich so
blöd geschaut wird ist ja also wer macht
denn den seitenrand schmaler wenn
überhaupt dann macht man verringert man
natürlich den zeilenabstand
na ja und das auch nicht allzusehr und
wenn man die arbeit digital abgeben muss
ist es leider auch schwierig sein kann
darauf dass nämlich ohne weiteres nach
schauen wenn man sie nur ausgedrückt
abgibt dann müsste er schon mit der lupe
und dem lineal nachmessen solange man es
nicht allzu dort trat aber den
seitenabstand das sieht ja sofort jemand
aber der schriftgröße bin ich übrigens
auch nicht schummeln
die ist übrigens mit times new roman 10
punkt auch schon helfen tief richtig
also in der kürze liegt die würze das
wollen wir jetzt auch für uns genau und
verabschieden uns deswegen aus dieser
woche wie üblich mit dem hinweis dass
ihr uns sehr gerne an faz einspruch
faz.de oder auf twitter dort findet ihr
uns jeweils unter unserem namen feedback
senden könnt und dass wir ganz besonders
erfreut werden wenn ihr uns auf itunes
eine sterne wertung hinterlasst genau
und sie können uns auch gerne einen
handgeschriebenen brief schicken
das würden wir doch schon lange nicht
mehr bekommen und dann belasse es dabei
wünschen eine wunderbare woche und
freuen uns auf den nächsten mittwoch